[Musik]
ein wunderschöner mittag erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen microsoft
fällt meine liebe freunde könnten
vielleicht schon ansehen ich bin denn es
hat aufgehört zu regnen also an alle
unter euch die vielleicht gerade bin
watching macht heißt wenn man sich
dieses komplette projekt hier
nacheinander anguckt dann wisst ihr
wahrscheinlich dass in der letzten
episode ist auch komplett geregnet hat
wir können dich erst mal ganz kurz ein
bisschen wieder aufpäppeln es hat in der
letzten episode ort endlich geschüttet
die in der welt und jetzt ist es auf
jeden fall wieder ziemlich aufgeheizt
hat dich hier vorne können wir auch mal
eben wieder ein bisschen reparieren so
ich möchte mal ganz kurz geben zu
unserem kollegen gehen der uns die
sachen ja verkaufen wollte also die
ender perlen der hatte nämlich immer
noch keine
blödmann dann haben wir hier ehrlich
gesagt auf der insel auch nichts mehr zu
suchen wir müssen nämlich zurück zu
meinem dorf bzw sich aber kein eigenes
dorf in minecraft war ich hab hunger
hunger übrigens meine lieben freunde mir
wird zahlreiche in die kommentare
geschrieben weil ich ja wieder ziemlich
lost unterwegs war und dachte dass
ofenkartoffeln das beste essen den
microsoft sind
irgendwie komischerweise nicht sondern
goldene karotten wurde mir geschrieben
also danke danke danke dafür den hinweis
hin hinweis wahrscheinlich
hin wollte schon da auf jeden fall für
eure hilfe in den kommentaren ich werde
auf jeden fall gleich mein restliches
knochenmehl nehmen und unten alle
kartoffeln und weizen sachen und keine
ahnung was ich noch in meiner
unterirdischen fahrbahn gebaut habe das
werde ich auf jeden fall als abreißen
oder abbauen abfangen keine ahnung was
der richtige begriff in der
landwirtschaft es allerdings wirklich
alles zu kleist mit karotten denn ich
habe so unmenschlich viel gold noch dass
ich das alles zu gold karotten machen
kann und das wird bis ende und für
meinen magen im ende eine extrem große
bereicherung sein allerdings und das
lieben freunde wohl noch mehr in die
kommentare geschrieben denn mir wurde
auch unter die arme gegriffen beim thema
phantom ihr wisst ihr dass ich immer
noch auf die phantome warte ich war
mittlerweile seit fünf nächten oder so
nicht schlafen in minecraft und
erstmal falls ihr vielleicht gerade neu
einsteigt ich glaube nicht dass
irgendwer jetzt gerade folge wo wir sind
96 glaub ich mittlerweile schon dass da
irgendwann neu dazu kommt bei dem
projekt aber ich warte immer noch auf
phantom und wir brauchen phantome in
dieser welt hier bzw
das was die phantome gruppen brauchen
wir es sind phantom heute und die müssen
wir in unserem bestand zu einem trank
des sanften falls verzaubern kenne mich
damit selber nicht so richtig aus
allerdings ist der tank des sanften
falls von ungeheurer wichtigkeit für
unsere and mission ist schön hier vorne
mit dem leuchtturm da hinten mit dem
ballon rechts daneben wir brauchen auf
jeden fall diesen sanften fall trank
definitiv bis ende weil wieder die ganze
zeit vor dem ende drachen hoch und
runter geschleudert werden allerdings
wollte ich ja gerade sagen dass wir das
mit dem phantom erklärt wurde und was
ist nicht so dass man drei nächte am
stück wach bleiben muss und dann wenn
die phantome da die wahrscheinlichkeit
steigert sich einfach nur also wenn ich
drei nächte am stück wach bin ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit irgendwie ein viertel
wenn ich dann vier nächte am stück wach
wenn es die wahrscheinlichkeit 25 also
das ist dann
eine geringere wahrscheinlichkeit ich
mathe genie das heißt allerdings dass
wir auf jeden fall weiterhin nicht
schlafen können beziehung war
erfahrung war es doch von der
ich relativ lange nicht mehr gegen
gehauen ich habe auch extrem lang nicht
mehr gegen den witz baumgart er erzählt
uns ja dann immer dann wird er einziger
witz wird deinen kampf gegen den ender
drachen sein
da muss ich dir widersprechen mir wurde
auch und in die kommentare geschrieben
dass ich jetzt bitte endlich mal meine
rüstungen hier reparieren soll ich weiß
nicht ob
das ist nicht dein ernst oder
nach schillig jetzt ist es sogar ein
gewitter
ok das heißt allerdings meine lieben
freunde das jetzt auch wieder monsters
bauen können von daher nutze ich die
zeit wo es jetzt gerade gewitter hat
einfach mal ganz kurz um euch erst mal
ganz kurz zu sagen dass ich meinen
rüsten auf jeden fall reparieren werde
das muss man auf jeden fall machen
allerdings eine ganz kurze zeit man
sachen hier sortiert
so meine lieben freunde ich habe gerade
meine sachen sortiert das war jetzt
einfach nur anderthalb minuten hat sich
die ta letztendlich gar nicht gelohnt
allerdings seht ihr schon unten dass
sich zwei karotten leider nur habe und
die muss ich jetzt hier so ein bisschen
mit knochenmehl befeuern da wurde mir
auch und in die kommentare geschrieben
irgendwann mal letztens ich werde den
kommentar nicht mehr finden deswegen
sorry das ist jetzt nicht anwenden
konnte allerdings hat nicht funktioniert
denn mir wurde geschrieben luca wenn
beispielsweise weizen anpflanzt kannst
du einfach mit rechtsklick
die nur das weizen holen und nicht die
samen dieser art bleiben dann stehen das
ist irgendwie da hätte wohl zeit gespart
und so allerdings funktioniert das nicht
in der version und der ich gerade spiele
spiele ich in der java version und nicht
irgendwie in der druckversion oder keine
ahnung wo das ganze funktioniert das
sind ja immer diese live hacks ein
bisschen bei mir -funktion das ganze auf
jeden fall leider nicht allerdings ganz
mehr als ihre karotten mehr kriege ich
gerade nicht hin am liebsten würde ich
euch jetzt gerade dann wenn wie hier
zwei stunden vorstellen dann klappt das
alles broda wir holen uns einfach
knochenmehl dadurch dass wir jetzt ein
paar skelette boxen gehen zunächst
müssen uns allerdings hier einen
kohleblock rausnehmen denn ich habe ja
hier einige kartoffeln noch am start und
die wollte ich auf jeden fall in den
ofen backen zuvor bekommt ihr beiden
allerdings ein verrottetes stück fleisch
und jetzt springt man mal ganz schnell
ist er irgendwas expediert
er hat der hexe getötet sonst wer hier
keinen zucker rausgekommen aber gut wir
sprinten auf jeden fall mal ganz fix
hier vorne zu unserem ofen und packen
ich habe die ganze zeit ein bisschen den
himmel weil ich hoffe dass irgendwelche
phantome kommen packe hier in den
kohleblock rhein und die kartoffel ich
weiß jetzt nicht mehr wurde auch
irgendwas in die kommentare geschrieben
von wegen luca du musst unter freiem
himmel seien damit von thomas bonn das
wage ich zu bezweifeln ob ich jetzt
schlafmangel drin oder draußen haben es
ja auch relativ un glaube ich dass
verortete fleisch packe ich noch mal
eben kurz in die kiste mit den sachen
die ich eigentlich nicht essen möchten
wir auch nicht essen darf weil wir
eigentlich gesagt haben lucano
tierische sachen essen also keine tiere
essen so ist richtig allerdings wenn ich
mich
schnell weg um das bett hier kann ich
mal mitnehmen das habe ich dir einer
hingesetzt damit ich nicht vergesse dass
ich nicht schlafen gehen darf ich war
jetzt auf jeden fall rüber hierzu
unserer kleinen abbau insel war früher
jetzt haben
[Musik]
war das jetzt ein schlechtes zeichen wir
haben hinten in skelett da werde ich
direkt mal eben rüber sprinten wir
brauchen nämlich so viel wie es geht
deswegen ist es heute ein komplettes
skelett jagd folge allerdings wollte ich
das ganze auch nutzen um euch so ein
bisschen den rechtlichen folgen plan zu
erklären da werde ich nämlich zugesperrt
in den kommentaren von wegen wie ist es
denn jetzt genau luca wirst du irgendwie
in folge 100 jetzt das ende gehen oder
schon eine folge frühjahr wie genau hast
du das geplant ich werde euch das heute
noch so ein bisschen erzählen was ich
das ehrlich gesagt jetzt so ein bisschen
erzählen hier kommt vielleicht eine
kleine mini baby an wir brauchen
eigentlich für das neue minecraft
projekt da wurde mir auch viel
geschrieben von wegen lukas 1.8 ist
schon draußen also die vorabversion die
will man aber irgendwie nicht spielen
weil da noch voll viele fehler drin sind
dann wurde mir auch geschrieben lukas
spiel 1.17 und dann die danach in
version 1.8 10 dann bekommst du auch die
krassen höhlen und so weiter und so fort
also dann muss ich mich auch nochmal ein
bisschen genauer informieren die sache
ist allerdings dass ich die letzten
folgen dieses minecraft mit luca projekt
wie folgt mir vorstelle habe ich die
frage mit ja also wir beschreiben wir
nicht beschreiben wir schreiben gerade
folge 96 heute ist die vorletzte
richtige folge also die folgen der ist
nicht um special sachen geht folge 97
also die folge die jetzt demnächst
kommen ich glaube nicht übermorgen
sondern in vier tagen ich weiß es nicht
genau ich muss bleibt gab einen
ablaufplan nicht so ganz kommt die sache
ist allerdings dass die nächste augen
direkt drei auf einmal die beiden
attackieren sich gegenseitig selbst auf
jeden fall sehr gut dann können wir hier
nur auf das hier drauf gehen die sache
ist dass die nächste folge also folgen
sieben und neun die halt wie
sind schon eine menge mops wir gerade
unterwegs sind hat die bayern jagen sich
hier wieder das glück geht auf mich aber
auf jeden fall ist diese folge zu folge
96 noch eine ganz normale folge und
folge 790 auch deswegen könnt ihr mir
jetzt bitte bitte bitte bitte gerne in
die kommentare schreiben leute die ja
den habe ich gar nicht gesehen
ihr könnt mir jetzt und in die
kommentare schreiben was ich in der
nächsten episode in folge 790 als letzte
normale m3 wächst hier
als letzte normale episode noch mal
machen soll also sollte ich noch mal
irgendwo hinfahren soll ich noch mal
irgendwas erkunden soll ich noch mal
eine ahnung wohin gehen in der höhle
jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt weil
die nächsten episoden danach also folge
hunderte schon action pur wird sollte
ich noch mal irgendeine kleinigkeit
bauen was ich in einer folge vielleicht
hinkriegen gegen das vergessen was ich
noch machen wollte unbedingt schreibt es
mir gerne in die kommentare was ich
heute nicht hier
die sind aber auch eine menge mops
unterwegs
also von leuten 2 max hier
leute 2 max hier
um auf den punkt zu kommen ich bin euch
sehr dankbar für alle kommentare was ich
in der nächsten episode minecraft mit
drucker machen soll dann diese folge und
lee bereits gesagt wollte hier
werden die letzten beiden richtigen
minecraft folgenden folge 98 wird eine
komplette vorbereitungs folge für das
ende da werde ich sachen verzaubern ich
werde nicht vorbereiten ich werde mir
den kürbis schnitzen die nicht mehr dann
auf den kopf setzte und so weiter und so
fort und die folge 99 also die vorletzte
folge dieses projekts generell wird eine
best of folge da habe ich alle möglichen
dateien herunter geladenen kollegen
geschickt und meinte alles was du willst
ich finde es was so cool findest was
spannend war was interessant war was
dumm war schneiders mal zusammen das
heißt da kommen locker 20 minuten langes
best of als folge 99 was wir uns
zusammen angucken werden in dieser welt
und dann erst folge 99 halt vorbei das
ist quasi das best-of da werden wir
nichts produktives machen sondern uns
noch mal angucken was wir alles erlebt
haben und folge 100 wird dann die ent
folge sein also so habe ich mir das
ganze vorgestellt so habe ich das ganze
geplant
jetzt mal ganz kurz die rein und
regeneriert noch ein bisschen leben
ihre nicht aber hier drin stehe kann ich
euch ganz kurz sagen freunde
habe ich voll und ganz recht passen so
folge 100 kommt auch neues merchandising
der insel geschafft
die salons flugrost wetter ist extrem
geil extrem fleißig so ein bisschen
vintage mäßig mit zum stück vorne drauf
und so und ein blauer pulli kommt auch
noch rein den habe ich jetzt gerade
nicht jene nämlich durch unterwäsche
möchte mit nach köln nehmen wollte dafür
produziere ich kann die videos vor
allerdings
hätte ja schon hier wir sind hier im
menü da wollte ich euch nämlich auch
kunst kurz vor zeigen und zwar ich mir
ein neues texture pack runtergeladen ihr
seht schon hier das no pumpkin blöd
texture pack gefragt wer jetzt
wahrscheinlich luca was macht das hier
habe ich einen geschnitzten kürbissen
wenn ich mit ihnen auf dem kopf setze
meine rüstung ist gut gegangen
dann
muss ich mir neue kräfte ihr seht schon
wenn ich diesen kürbis auf dem kopf habe
sieht man fast gar nichts mehr also eine
hälfte des bildschirms locker ist
komplett schwarz nur doch das liegt
daran weil ich halt diesen kurs offen
compal ist ja logisch und ich brauche
diesen kürbis auf den kopf weil wenn ich
damit ein endermann angucke dann greift
er mich nicht an die sache ist
allerdings dass das natürlich ziemlich
stört gerade euch als zuschauer man
sieht halt fast nichts deswegen habe ich
mir dieses expect runtergeladen und wenn
ich dieses tags speck ist rein packe
jetzt erstmal ganz kleinen augenblick
allerdings sehen wir dann schon
gravis auf den kopf aber
sie trotzdem noch alles klar kann man
jetzt sagen das ist natürlich irgendwie
cheaten weil man mehr sieht also für
mich als spieler ja stimmt auch bin ich
auch dankbar für die sache ist
allerdings dass ich da wirklich primär
an euch denke so dass ihr das komplette
erlebnis hat bei folge 100 und nicht
irgendwie die hälfte vom spiel nicht
irgendwie sehen könnt nur weil da der
pumpkin alles verdeckt von daher hoffe
ich mal dass ihr okay seit mit der
entscheidung dass ich mir dieses pack
runtergeladen habe ich glaube es wird
halt für folge 100 mit deutliche
bereicherung sein und meine lieben
freunde was mir auch noch in die
kommentare geschrieben wurde war
[Musik]
ich habe alles abgearbeitet
das war die produktivste minecraft mit
luca folge aller zeiten also für mich
ich bin der aufnahme bei 24 minuten und
ich bin durch mit meinem plan
was wahrscheinlich extrem wenig
geschnitten haben allerdings es hat
aufgehört zu regnen ok perfekt dann kann
ich mich jetzt mal ganz kurz um die
karotten kümmern da muss man nämlich
einfach eine karotte in die mitte legen
und drumherum goldbarren dann
da muss man nämlich noch eine karotte in
die mitte legen und drumherum
goldklumpen davon habe ich ja sogar noch
eine menge dann kann man das ja einfach
damit machen also hier chuck goldblum
rum drumherum so dann können wir uns die
ganz ganz viele goldene karotten machen
ich weiß nicht wie viele gold machen ich
dafür noch benötige ich mache mir jetzt
einfach mal ein paar ich meine was soll
der geiz das projekt ist schon fast
vorbei also ihr hier alle drum herum
zakir hier alle drum herum dann brauche
ich sogar noch ein paar mehr so dass ich
das hinkriege aber hiermit sollte es
jetzt brauch ich definitiv reichen sagt
so jetzt hat mit 25 goldene karotten und
können damit auf jeden fall denke ich
dass am ende ganz gut meistern das
reisen ist mir gerade aus der hand
gerutscht das pack ich
komme da nicht dran
dankeschön das eisen packe ich auch noch
mal ganz kurz hier rein und werde jetzt
auch mal wieder den kürbis gegen meinen
diamant helm tauschen das bettchen das
nehme ich mir sicher sein damit ich am
fetten popel alltag
weg die spinnen augen kommen hier rein
der seidene faden hier vorne die
rollenden karotten packe ich
sicherheitshalber mal hier erstmal die
ganzen sachen einfach das fleisch
braucht auch nicht bedienen kann ich
doch mal nun bei den zahlen geben da die
klamotten packen erst mal hier rein weil
die ziemlich wichtig sind jetzt gehen
wir mal ganz fix eben zur blue kriegs
ein fleischstück und balenciaga und wir
haben immer noch kein phantom und leute
treiben leute treiben wächst hier
ich bin vom doline
erst droht ich weiß jetzt nicht wo der
andere kripo hier
beide creeper tod ich weiß nicht warum
hier so viele krippe auf dieser map sind
es regt mich auch einfach nur noch auf
die sache ist allerdings meine lieben
freunde dass ich an der stelle die
heutige episode minecraft mit luca jetzt
auch beenden würde ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen wenn es das getan hat dann das
kann einen daumen hoch unter dem video
hier da es war krass ich dachte die
phantome kommen wollte weil die
wahrscheinlichkeit steigt allerdings
können dann in der nächsten folge auch
noch nicht schlafen gehen und ich hoffe
dass dann wenigstens ein phantom kommt
und was sich in der nächsten folge also
der quasi letzten richtigen folge
minecraft mit luca wo ich frei in dem
was ich machen kann machen soll das
gerne und den kommentare wie bereits
gesagt folge 98 wird dann die
vorbereitungs folge für seine folgen 99
besten folge 100 dann die letzte folge
dieses projekt ist minecraft mit flug ab
wenn es euch gefallen hat das gerne
einen daumen hoch unter dem video aber
nicht meinen kanal und klickt auf die
glocke damit der neue videos nicht
verpassen und wir wir uns ein paar tagen
wieder
[Musik]